hello and welcome to this video player
national Muslim em Western soul that's
an English opening is a really freaking
opponent a 28 games I have a plus one
score heart check hard-fought games did
I've it's 95 earlier maybe maybe
hmm Jim already disliked it this is not
how it should be ready do you have to
play 95 your first no not anyway let's
see what happens I this I've got a good
development here so I shouldn't be in
big trouble of course it's not ideal if
you have to give up the bishop pair that
early and ok but now check this actually
looks dangerous for black so night eight
where I guess I have to
yeah okay this is a wager probably not
lose the before pawn but still not a
very happy move so how do we do the CRX
SI one I wonder if actually be three as
a nation add sir let's improve this
piece here first I look to the C file
doesn't feel extremely pressing
[Music]
[Music]
wow that's that's very ambitious I don't
think he considered this that he will
give up this pawn I have 96 is the main
thing okay but knight c6 now is probably
not good I think I just go back my king
position is pretty safe okay he doesn't
seem to agree so each for ya so what to
do 24 unfortunately I cannot play will
be three queen bee six looks good if he
goes rupee at the screen c3 also not bad
huh isn't it couldn't be six good now
which what's the point let's do it my
ass no here's a good square voice queen
yeah here I have Queen a six just take
the take the pawn
[Music]
in night on d3 is fantastic piece what
check black resigns okay I say now that
I screwed up the opening with maybe I
didn't normally what gets in an early 95
this is smooth autumn this move all over
the a-6 p yes for this felt like a
screwed-up summer after look it up yeah
yeah I mean one thing at least this is
kind of quick my development but you
should probably cancel it's that the
engine gives gives black a slight
advantage here this is this is possible
that black really has something but most
of the time this will kind of evaporate
and nothing happens and this is probably
a little bit less precise energy form
[Music]
for sacrifices let that make sense out
of Queen B 6 at least check the engines
line and black is better now suddenly as
usual it's hard to say with rooks and
pawns against two pieces how much this
but black is better yeah this is prolly
check turning it around a little bit
each that's better than this
and I think I played it quite okay from
here and I'd see one is a good move is
this luke c100 this is good in g5 I
think this is a tad too much yeah i
don't know i think this is a good one
queen bee six if he goes rupee eight
here I know pt3 with the tempo and this
is a really good reply and you know it
will be seven was already better but
this is also strong yeah he has to take
basically and this is losing i mean i
will take a six and we win with my be
born yeah this was not helping there's
III and everything Roxy one the note how
strong the night is and it's a really
strong piece covering f2 and covering
all kinds of important squares okay
thanks for watching